you don't like the taste of losing I
want to do my personal brand there's a
lot of fear and right now I feel like I
want to I want to step off of my comfort
zone and but then there's still a lot of
fear of what of like getting being
judged and also I really like my post
and by my friends if they're your
friends don't support you they could
judge you in the beginning but they'll
support you in the end yeah but I still
have doubts in myself like every time I
post content like in a few days I would
just delete it because like there's a
lot of noise in my head and no no you're
deleting it because it didn't do well if
you don't like the video if there were
five views
you don't like the taste of losing
I'm very competitive person me too so
every time I see like it's not working
out
I'm extremely competitive but you must
have humility you need humility I'm
competitive too but when I lose you have
to accept it I didn't shoot well
upstairs with my basketball pissed as
[__] still right now but I have to
accept it you have to add humility to
your repertoire that's what you're
worried about